Since I got back from combat I've I
spent seven years trying to fix myself
and bury everything and tell me nothing
was wrong. Since starting my treatment
about three, I say, three years ago I have
thought I've gotten better I've seen a
lot of improvement. I will step back from
the treatment but I've never fully
stopped the treatment because I see the
progress and things are getting easier. I
can go out in public again
I can be in a crowd I'm able to go do
things with my children now.
It was a struggle every day to get up, you know, to
go to sleep, you know, I have a service
dog. Five years ago, even two years
ago, somebody cut me off on the
Expressway coming to Boston; me, if I
didn't chase him down and throw a finger
or... That was the norm.
I was in the Air Force for one month shy of 15 years
I had two combat deployments, Iraq in '05
and Afghanistan in '07 both
with army units as a ground medic
there's a lot of guilt
all of the
guys that didn't come home that were
under my care I was holding in and
blaming myself for
and carrying that
with you for a couple years
a lot of stronger emotions that stem
from
hating yourself for
not being better
I was medivacked out of Iraq in May of
'03 after I spent '01 and '02 in
Afghanistan right after 9/11. They
discharged me in January of '04 and I
hadn't gone back to work at the Navy for
like six months. I was a lieutenant
commander and I just disappeared off the
face of the earth
I was married, kids, you know, we ended up
moving up into the middle of the mountains
up in Seattle, near Seattle, Washington, up in the Cascades
you know, it was basically a place to run
to and hide.
One of the ways that we
hope that veterans and the family
members eventually will be able to
express themselves in a way that works
for them is through making a song which
we're calling collaborative songwriting
so it's both the process of making the
song with a songwriter as well as the
process of listening to the song that we
really hope will help veterans express
themselves and think about and process
their thoughts and feelings and
behaviors in a way but they may not have
done before.
Probably one of the most emotional...
emotionally draining and
I would even say was almost physically and
mentally draining as well, experiences
over that a couple hours that I sat with
Jim and came up with a song which was
hard to believe and it was all about
telling the story.
The writer that I
worked with definitely was very easy to
talk to
I forgot that I was talking about myself
at parts and it definitely helped break
down some of the walls when you're
working with a counselor you tend to
keep some walls up because you're always
afraid of giving too much information
when he was writing the song the walls
came down because I just wanted to
finish the song
There's a real power to
some of those songs because they were
written by someone that lived that
powerful experience
I'll tell you for
the first week it was pretty goddamn
difficult listening to that without
crying, you know, I'd shared it with my family, my
wife, my children, I want to say it's
definitely opened their eyes as to kind
of giving them an inkling of what I've
been through
especially, you know, my kids, you know,
they're 12, 14, and 15 and I feel like I
missed the whole first 10 years of their
life and in the song I thought, you know,
my kids will never know what I was like
before all of this.
I was actually listening
to it twice most days when I started
getting frustrated, put the song on and
it kind of grounded me
it made me think of traffic sucks, I'm
gonna get through it, my day can get
better from there.
When I listen to it quiet at home at
night, hey I'm dealing with this problem today
tomorrow's a new day. It served as an
inspiration to remind me of the path I'm on
This study was really to see, does
collaborative songwriting help veterans
we didn't really ask the question what
is it about collaborative songwriting
that helps them to feel better so we
essentially gave everyone a Fitbit and
we tracked both their physiological
outcomes such as heart rate number of
steps and sleep quality as well
psychological outcomes at the beginning
of the study and at the end of the study. We're really lucky to be in this
environment through Harvard Medical
School and through the hospital system
where we can collaborate with others
doing really interesting work in
mindfulness and meditation and other
complementary therapies that you can
actually measure something that is
serological, a measure a biomarker that
we can further validate what we're what
we're showing
My PTSD has affected my family and
again that's the part that really hit
home for me was I'm a good dad now
I have it in me with a little more
treatment to be a great dad.